こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです
2年ほど前の話でしょうか
クリスマスの日に 僕の家にストーカーの方が入り込んできて
事件になった話があったと思うんですが
私がこの家に住んでいて あの事件とは別にも
数々の色んな方がうちに来ることがありました
今回の動画ではその中でも特に僕の中の記憶に残っている
あの人はストーカーだったのか はたまたストーカーじゃなかったのか
という
凄い絶妙な????だったので僕は何とも言えないんですけども
そんな何とも言えない事件が起きたことを
今日は皆さんにお話しようと思います
事件が起きたのは
だいぶ昔だった気がしますね
今多分事項というか
結構日がたっているから言っちゃっても大丈夫かなと思ってるんですけども
やっぱりですね色んな人が家に来るわけですよ
恐らく3年ぐらい前だった気がするんですけども
あ
もうちょい恐いかんじでいきますね
当時私はじめしゃちょーは
外で動画を撮影している機会が多くあり
シャッターの近くで動画を撮っていました
その日は 天気が悪く
ポツポツと 雨が降りはじめ
日が暮れる頃には 大雨に変わっていたのです
撮影が終わり 僕は家の中に戻って
動画編集しようとしていると
家の外から
1人の女性が すいませんと 私に 声をかけ
覚えてねぇな3年前だからうっすらなんですよね
ぁ...戻ります
すいませんと声をかけられ 当時の私は
まだ 心が優しく
まぁ、今も優しいんですけど(...)
より優しく(...) 困ってる人がいると
ほおっておけない性格だったわけです
まぁ今もそうなんですけど(...)
どうしましたか と聞いてみると
その女性は
そう私に声をかけてきたのです
話を聞くと その女性駅から降りて
歩いて うちの近くまで来ていたのですが
駅からイトーヨーカドーは 私の家の
真逆の方向にあるんです
おや
私は一瞬 怪しいと思いながらも話を聞いてみると
確か記憶が正しければ
行く理由とかあんまり深く聞くと良くないなと思って
特に理由は聞かなかったですけど
その女性は イトーヨーカドーに行きたいと 言っていました
そして私はその女性にイトーヨーカドーへの行き方を教えると
その女性は
顔を曇らせ
そう私に 言ったのです
私は完全に怪しみました
いやお前、普通に歩いていけばええやん!
と、言いたい所だったのですが
その女性 雨のせいで 服が ﾋﾞｯｼｮﾋﾞｼｮに濡れていました
皆さんの想像する ちょっと濡れたかんじではなく
もう髪の毛から服までﾋﾞｼｬﾋﾞｼｬに濡れてて
どうしよう
てなっちゃう感じでした
私の記憶が正しければ
コンビニでタオルを買ってタオルをあげて
傘も渡したんですけども
こうとうの行き方と私はイトーヨーカドーに行けない
スマホの電池も切れている
なんとかして私をイトーヨーカドーまで送ってくれませんかと言われ
私はとても悩みました
この人は本当に困っているのだろうか
いや、でも!
イトーヨーカドーって真逆じゃね?
でうちの住所もバレてるし
何かめっちゃ濡れてたし本当に迷ってるのか
ピンポイントでうちに来て
知らない人に車で乗せていってくれませんか
んでちょっと怪しいなと思ったし
てかタクシー使えばよくね?
と色々考えたんですけど
その話を踏まえその女性に関する
特徴的な部分が4つほどありました
1つ目 目的地が駅と真反対の方向にある
これ非常に怪しいポイントだなと思いました
僕の家がイトーヨーカドーと同じ方向とか近くであれば
まぁ全然 んまぁ不自然ではあるんですけども
まぁ利には適ってるかなと
ですが駅から見てイトーヨーカドーの真逆なんで
それでうちのピンポイントはちょっと怪しいなと思った部分があった
2つ目 めちゃくちゃ濡れていました
これは何かもう人として何とかしてあげなきゃと思っちゃったんで
タオルとか買ってあげたんですけど
まぁ天気予報見ろよと
天気予報見たらもう分かるだろうなとか思ったり
傘買ってから来なよとか
そもそも駅からイトーヨーカドーは遠いので
濡れてるのも怪しいなとか思ったりもしました
んちょっと考えすぎかも知れないです
3つ目 イトーヨーカドーまで送ってください
これがちょっと僕は怪しいなと思いました
まぁ普通の考えではですよ
僕だと知らない人の車に乗るとかありえないし
見ず知らずの人に乗せてってくれませんか何てもう
無理だし
それなのにピンポイントでうちに来て
そういうこと言ってるってことは
まぁストーカーまではいかないんですけど
何かしらそういう会いに来ようとしてることなのかなという気はしました
4つ目
その後色々な状況を見て
まぁ僕も動画編集しなきゃいけないし
天気もめちゃくちゃ悪いし
その方も凄いビショビショで何か弱ってたんで
何とかしなきゃと思って
結局
車に乗せてバァーと行ってすぐイトーヨーカドーで降ろしたんですけど
イトーヨーカドーにその女性を送って降りる瞬間
1枚の手紙を貰いました
内容を見ると連絡先と何かしらの形でお礼をしたいので
今度良かったらご飯でもどうですかという内容の手紙でした
何で助けられる前提でその手紙を持っていたのでしょう
そこで私は気づいてしまいました
この人確信犯だということを
ていう話が実はありました
いや何か3年前だから何か凄いまだ僕もチャランポラン(?)してて
うちに来る人もまだ優しかった時期だったんで
今だったら絶対しないです今だったら
困っている人も多分すぐ警察の方に連絡で対処するんですけど
まぁで多分そういうことがあったなと思って
ちょっと今回はお話してみました
まぁもちろんなんですけど貰った手紙はそのまま処分させていただいて
まぁその女性はその後一切何も無かったんですけど
まぁ何か今なら言えるけどちょっとやり方がずるいなというか
助けられる前提で手紙まで書いてありますからね
多分僕がそうやってくれるってのを予知して
うちまで来てたのかなと僕だと思っちゃいました
真相は分からないんですけど
もし本当にそういう目的で来てるのであれば
めっっちゃ計算高いなと思ったという話でございました
行きたい所が真逆にある訳なんですよ
濡れてるからもうそりゃ心配になるし
その人お金も無いしスマホも電源切れてるしっていう何も無いから
何かそろそろやった人も多分忘れてるだろうなーと思って
動画にさせていただきました
そういうことがあってねーもう思ったんすよ
ED
ﾊﾟｧｧーーーーーーーー
ﾊﾟﾗﾗﾗーﾗｧーー
ﾊﾟﾗﾗﾗｧーー
ﾗﾗﾗﾗーﾗｧーー
ﾗﾗﾗﾗｧー
ﾗｧー(↑)ﾗﾗ
ﾗﾗﾗﾗｧーﾗｧーﾗｧー
ﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯ
☆ﾊﾟ☆ｲ☆ﾅ☆ｯ☆ﾌﾟ☆ｯ☆ﾙ☆ｯ☆
バイバーイ